[موسيقى]
في مقابله مع القناه الاسرائيليه الثانيه
قال الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس انه لا
يحق له العيش في البلده التي هجر منها عام
48 وانما يحق له رؤيتها
[موسيقى]
فقط
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في عنوانين
رئيسيين هل سيرضى الفلسطينيون بحق الرؤيا
بديلا عن حق العوده وما الثمن الذي يرجوه
عباس من تصريحاته في وقت لا مفاوضات
فيه ما يعتقد اننا قادرون على اعاده كل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الى اسرائيل رغم من
عنها فعليه ان يعرف ان ذلك سيعني اننا
هزمنا اسرائيل وراح اليهود هكذا فسر نمر
حماد مستشار الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
تصريحات الاخير للتلفزيون الاسرائيلي موقف
ليس بالجديد قال حماد داعيا الشعب
الفلسطيني الى التخلي عن الشعارات الكبيره
حسب تعبيره لكن الموقف الفلسطيني الاخير
اعتبر من قبل السياسيين ومراقبين تنازلا
عن حق العوده الذي شكل الشراره التي اطلقت
منها حركه التحرير
الفلسطينيه من حق العوده الى حق
الرؤيه اشتهي رؤيه صفت ذلك من
حقي لكن ليس من حقي ان اقيم فيها فلسطين
في نظري الان هي حدود عام 67 مع القدس
الشرقيه عاصمه لها الان والى
الابد ذلك على الخريطه اما في الواقع فان
كلامه لا ينطبق الا على ما ابقاه
الاستيطان من الضفه الغربيه لطالما اتهمت
السلطه الفلسطينيه بانها مهووسه بتحسين
صوره المطالب الفلسطينيه في عيون الدول
الكبرى بمواقف يتضح لاحقا انها لا تحسن
الصوره ولا توقف
الاستيطان يفضل الرئيس محمود عباس السبل
الدبلوماسيه لاستعاده
الحقوق ما دمت في السلطه فلن تحدث انتفاضه
ثثه
لكن هل احراج اسرائيل في المحافل الدوليه
يجعلها مثلا تعيد الاراضي
المغصوبه وضع محللون تصريحات عباس في سياق
محاوله منه للتاثير على الناخبين
الاسرائيليين في الثان من يناير المقبل
ومحاوله لاتصال مبكر مع الرئيس الامريكي
المقبل لكن رد حماس كان
كالمتيم لاحد كائن من كان شخص او رئيس
منظمه او سلطه او حكومه او منظمه ان
تتنازل عن شبر واحد من هذه الارض
الفلسطينيه او ان تتنازل عن حق العوده
لارضنا وديارنا التي هجرنا منها ليس
تنازلا ولكنه تعامل مع امر واقع يقول احد
مستشاري الرئيس محمود عباس من يعتقد انه
يمكن ان نعيد كل اللاجئين واحفادهم
واولادهم وكذا الى اسرائيل رغما عنها 5
مليون هذا بكل بساطه معنى ذلك هذا الشخص
لازم يكون حاطط براسه انه احنا هزمنا
اسرائيل ووصلنا لتل ابيب ورجعت كل الناس
وراحوا اليهود في المقابل تنظر اسرائيل
الى اليهود الذين غادروا دولا عربيه طوعا
وايمانا منهم بما يسمى ارض الميعاد على
انهم لاجئون وكانهم اخرجوا من اوطانهم وهم
بمنطقها المكافئ للاجئين الفلسطينيين بحيث
تنتهي ماسه شعب بتعادل خيالي تقرره
اسرائيل
وحدها لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
عمان الكاتب والمحلل السياسي فايز رشيد
ومن رام الله الكاتب والمحلل السياسي سميح
شبيب سيد سميح هل ما فهم من كلام الرئيس
محمود عباس هو دعوه هو اقرار الى اسقاط حق
العوده بالنسبه للاجئين الفلسطينيين ام
هذا ليس
دقيق لا ليس دقيقا على الاطلاق هو ف خاطئ
او قراءه خاطئه في سياقات خاطئه وتوظيف
خاطئ ايضا ما انا استمعت الى المقابله
اكثر من مره التي ادل بها الرئيس محمود
عباس للقناه الثانيه
الاسرائيليه ولم اجد فيها اي جمله او
اشاره الى اسقاط حق العوده هو صحيح اذا في
هذه
الحاله هذ هنالك لغه دبلوماسيه
استخدمها الرئيس على اعتاب الانتخابات
الكنيست الاسرائيليه والكلام موجه للشارع
الاسرائيلي ولا يوجد اي تنازل عن الاسس او
الخطوط الحمراء ا ولكن فقط لاعيد م قاله
الرئيس عباس حتى نفهم م قاله بشكل دقيق لو
اخطا الرئيس عباس سيقول اخطات اه قال انا
من حقي ان ازور صفد بلدتي ولكن ليس من حقي
ان اقيم
فيها اليس هذا كلاما واضحا ودقيقا بان
مفهوم حق العوده اصبح جزء من
الماضي الكلام في هذا السياق هو انني انا
من يافا مثلا ولكن اقدر ازور يافا ولا
استطيع العيش فيها من الذي
يمنعني من يمنعني هو اسرائيل هذا واحد
واحد ثاني حق العوده هو وفقا للمقررات
الشرعيه الدوليه وهذا ما يحتاج الى
تفاوض انا استمعت الى هذه الجمله في حديث
الرئيس وفهمت منها ان هنالك قوه
اسرائيليه تتحكم في مسار الامور وتعطل
مسار
المفاوضات عانيه في الاساس في ه الحاله
سيد سميح كيف
يفهم ما صرح به السيد نمر حماد شار الرئيس
بان هذا ليس بجديد ما قاله الرئيس
الفلسطيني وان على الشعب الفلسطيني ان
يتخلى عما سماه
شعارات لا ايضا ايضا نمر حماد لم يقل ذلك
بهذا السياق الذي ذكرته ما قاله ان حق
العوده هو حق حقيقي شخصي قابل للمفاوضات
ولكن من يعتقد ان الامور هي كما كانت في
في عام
1948 فهو واهم وخاطئ هنالك مستجدات كثيره
حصلت حصلت في الجانب الفلسطيني ديموغرافيه
وغير ديموغرافيه وفي الجانب الاسرائيلي
وهذا يحتاج الى مفاوضات وفقا لمقررات
الشرعيه الدوليه اما ان هنالك اسقاطا لهذا
الحق فهذا امر غير ممكن لا احد يمتلك هذا
الحق لا الرئيس محمود عباس ولا اي قائد
سياسي اخر ما دمت انت قد فهمت تصريح
الرئيس محمود عباس بهذا الشكل دعني اسال
ضيفي من عمان السيد فيز رشيد ان كان قد
فهم ايضا تصريح الرئيس محمود عباس بنفس
الطريقه يعني في تقديري الدبلوماسيه او
نحن في وضع دبلوماسي تبرير غير معقول
مطلقا لما جرى او للتصريحات التي قالها
عباس في اعتقادي انه في الوقت الذي يعني
تكشف فيه اسرائيل بانها اغتالت ابو جهاد
وفي الوقت الذي تمر فيه الذكرى 95 لوعد
بالفر وفي الوقت الذي يزداد فيه
الاستيطان وفي الوقت الذي تكثف اسرائيل من
غاراتها على شعبنا الفلسطيني ياتي الرئيس
عباس بمنتهى الوضوح ليقول انني اتخلى عن
حق العوده هذا دون دبلوماسيه ودون يعني
تعقيد للامور وصف سطه للامور باختصار شديد
في تقديري انه قال اذا يعني احنا نحن نريد
دوله على حدود
67 محمود محمود عباس للعلم في وثيقه في
1995 يعني مسماه وثيقه عباس بلن يعني راه
على او تخلى عن حق العوده و العلم كان هذا
الاتفاق من المفترض ان يعلنوا اسحاق رابين
في عام
1995 لكن قتل اسحاق رابين قبل ان يعلن هذا
الاتفاق ولكن سيد فايز سيد فايز سيد فايز
اذا كان هذا ع عفوا عفوا اذا كان هذا مقصد
الرئيس محمود عباس في ظل الظروف التي ذكرت
يضاف لها الا مفاوضات الان اذا ما الذي
يدفع الرئيس محمود عباس الى هذه الخطوه
الخطيره وما قد ينجر
عنها صديقي العزيز باختصار شديد الرئيس
عباس يعني حشر نفسه في زاويه ضيقه اسمها
زاويه المفاوضات ثم المفاوضات ثم
المفاوضات هو يعتبر اي شكل حتى الانتفاضه
الثالثه يقول لن اسمح بها طالما بقيت في
الحكم ما معنى ذلك الذي يقرر الانتفاضه
الثالثه ليس محمود عباس ولا اي قائد
فلسطيني مثلما انطلقت الانتفاضه الاولى
والثانيه ستنطلق الانتفاضه الثالثه محمود
ح محمود عباس بالمعنى الفعلي يعني اختار
المفاوضات واكد في لقاؤه مع القناه
الثانيه للتلفزيون الاسرائيلي بان خياره
من خلال الدبلوماسيه والسياسي دعونا نقول
يا عالم بالله عليكم هل من المستح هل من
المعقول انه وبعد 20 سنه من المفاوضات
التي ادت الى مزيد من الكوارث والويلات
على شعبنا الفلسطيني الاستيطان زاد اضعافا
مضاعفه بعد اتفاقيات اوشو طيب لنبقى لنبقى
فقط ان الموضوع الفلسطيني متشعب جدا لنبقى
في موضوع حق العوده بالنسبه للاجئين وهنا
اتوجه بسؤال ضيفي السيد سميح قلت قبل قليل
بان ما قاله الرئيس الفلسطيني انما هو
للاستهلاك الاعلامي موجه لجمهور اسرائيلي
ما الغرض من
ذلك ما قلته ان هذا اللقاء هو موجه للشارع
الاسرائيلي ما قبل الانتخابات التشريعيه
الاسرائيليه انتخابات الكنيست وهذا الكلام
الموجه للجانب الاسرائيلي ياتي في سياق
معركه سياسيه مع الاسرائيليين هنالك معركه
سياسيه بين السلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
وبين اسرائيل ا كانان يتعلق بالمفاوضات او
مستقبل الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المفاوضات وصلت الى طريق شبه
مسدود نتيجه التعنت الاسرائيلي
اليميني التعنت الليكود واسرائيل بيتنا
وشاس وغيرها الشارع الاسرائيلي عليه ان
يدرك ان الجانب الفلسطيني يريد حقوقه
الوطنيه المشروعه التي اقرتها المجالس
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وهي اراضي الرابع من
حزيران في القدس والضفه الغربيه وغزه هذا
كلام واضح المعركه السياسيه الان وبعد
توقف غير قصير
للمفاوضات زها عامين الان هنالك توجه
فلسطيني سياسي شجاع نحو الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده لانتزاع قرار دوله بصفه غير
الع
هذا سيترتب عليه امور سياسيه كثيره هذه
الاراضي لن تكون اراضي متنازع عليها وغير
قابله للتفاوض هي اراضي محتله وسيترتب
عليها بان الاستيطان غير شرعي وعمل عدواني
والجدار ايضا طيب يعني ايضا ايضا ايضا
دخلنا في موضوعات اخرى لنبقى في مساله هذا
التصريح بالذات لان وقت البرنامج تعرفون
ضيق ولا يسمح بالتش عب في الكثير من
القضايا وهنا اتوجه بسؤالي مره اخرى الى
ضيفي في عمان السيد فايز سعيد اذا كان
الرئيس عباس يعني ما يقول فيما يتعلق بحق
بحق العوده بالنسبه
للاجئين فما الذي يجعله يتكلم الى قناه
تلفزيونيه بهذا الشكل المقتضب عن هذه الم
المساله هناك قنوات اخرى كان بامكانه ان
يمضي فيها اذا كان فعلا يعني هذه
الخطوه يعني في اعتقادي اولا ان محاوري لم
لم يعرف او لم يطلع على معطيات
الاستطلاعات الاسرائيليه مطلقا لان كافه
استطلاعات الراي وخصوصا بعد تحالف ليبرمان
نتنياهو تؤدي كلها او تشي كلها بان اليمين
الصهيوني هو الذي سيحوز على اكبر عدد ممكن
من المقاعد في تاريخه في داخل الكيان
الصهيوني هذا اولا المساله الثانيه انه
وكانه يعني صك براءه اراد عباس ان يقدم
للاسرائيليين من حق العوده واحد ومن
الكفاح المسلح اثنين ومن كافه اشكال
المقاومه ايضا ثلاث هو هو هو هو
لطالما طلع علينا بشعارات كثيره مثل حل
السلطه مثل يعني والان ياتي التخلي عن حق
العوده هو يريد ان يطمئن الاسرائيليين
باننا لن نطالب بمثل هذا الحق مطلقا طيب
هذا في
اعتقادي ارا مره اخرى لسؤالك عن ما اشرت
له بان هذا الكلام موجه للناخب الاسرائيلي
او الجمهور الاسرايلي ولو تفضلت فقط اجبني
بسرعه لان لدينا فاصل بعد قليل ما الذي
يفهمه الجمهور الاسرائيلي عندما يسمع من
الرئيس عباس بانه من حقه ان يزور صفد ولكن
ليس من حقه العيش
فيها
يعني الشارع الاسرائيلي ليس واحدا صحيح ان
الشارع الاسرائيلي يتجه نحو اليمين
وانا اعتقد انني اتابع ليس استطلاعات
الراي الاسرائيليه فقط بل وصحف ايضا
والاراء وغير ذلك ولكن هذا لا يمنعنا من
ان نخاطب الشارع الاسرائيلي وان نحاول ان
نؤثر في الشارع الاسرائيلي ما يدركه
الشارع الاسرائيلي من هذا الكلام ان شخصا
قد ولد في مدينه فلسطينيه وحرم من الاقامه
بها وان التسويه التاريخيه الكبرى
تقتضي ان تكون هنالك دوله هي دوله اسرائيل
التي نحن نقر بوجودها ولكن مقابل الاعتراف
الاسرائيلي والاقرار بدوله فلسطينيه على
حدود الرابع من حزيران في الجزء الثاني من
هذه الحلقه سنناقش ان كان لهذه الخطوه من
قبل الرئيس عباس اهداف فما الثمن المنتظر
بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه
واجد تحيه بضيفي من عمان ومن رم الله
واتوجه لعمان ضيفي من هناك السيد فايز
رشيد الكاتب والمحلل السياسي لنفهم تفسير
هذه الخطوه والهدف منها ان كان المراد
منها مقابل السلطه الفلسطينيه الرئيس عباس
سيتوجه للجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده في
خطوه توصف بالتاريخ من اجل الاعتراف
بالدوله الفلسطينيه ما الذي يدفعه الى هذا
التنازل الى هذه الفكره طبعا ان كان ما
قاله الرئيس عباس يعنيه فيما يتعلق باسقاط
حق عوده
اللاجئين صديقي العزيز بدايه اود التاكيد
على ان اذا الرئيس محمود عباس ونمر حماد
ومن معهما تخلوا عن حق العوده فهناك 9
ملايين فلسطيني عمليا يطالبون بهذا الحق
والعوده الى اراضيهم وديارهم ومعاهم 300
مليون عربي ايضا وكل
الانسانيين الذين يعني يساندوا القضيه
الفلسطينيه هذا اولا المساله الثانيه انا
من الناس اللي اعتقد ان حقي في فلسطين من
البحر الى النهر يعني وكل فلسطين ونعم صفد
قبل
رساله هذه هذه رساله لواشنطن من خلال تل
ابيب يدرك محمود عباس ان امكانيه تاثير
اسرائيل على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
امكانيه قائمه هو يريد ان يرضي
الاسرائيليين هو يستعطف الاسرائيليين كي
يؤثروا على الامم المتحده في تقديري على
الامريكيين ليؤثر بدورهم على الامم
المتحده
للاعتراف بالخطوه التي تقدمت بها منظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه للجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده من اجل قبول فلسطين دوله غير غير
عضو او دوله مراقبه هذا ه هذه المساله
الاساسيه هو ارسل رساله من قبل للرئيس
اوباما يؤكد فيها على ان اننا نريد من هذه
الخطوه الفلسطينيه ان نعود الى المفاوضات
مره اخرى نعود للمفاوضات مره اخرى
باعتبارنا دوله محتله طيب في ظل اللاءات
الاسرائيليه الكثيره التي قيلت منذ زمن
بعيد وما تزال لغايه الان ماذا ممكن ان
يحصل محمود عباس سوى المزيد من الاستيطان
المزيد من مصارد من مصادره الاراضي وهكذا
دعني انقل دعني انقل سيد فايز دعني انقل
كانت يتعلق بالمستوطنات
وتوقفها ليفي في رام الله السيد سميع اذا
كان الوضع هكذا سواء جاءت الحكومه من
اليسار او من اليمين او من اقصى اليمين ما
دام الوضع الفلسطينيه على حاله اذا لماذا
يغامر الرئيس الفلسطيني بهذه الورقه وان
كانت من اجل هدف اعلامي هدف تلفزيوني موجه
للجمهور
الاسرائيلي يا اخي لا توجد لا مغامره ولا
مقامره المقابله مع القناه الثانيه
الاسرائيليه لم
تتضمن اي جمله او اشاره للتخلي عن حق
العوده علينا ان نقرا نص بشكل واعي بشكل
دقيق وان نتفق اذا كان هذا صحيحا ام لا
هذه نقطه نقطه ثانيه وهامه جدا نحن
كفلسطينيين نخوض الان معركه سياسيه هذه
المعركه السياسيه من يدرك الف باء السياسه
يعرف ان التوجه للامم المتحده يعني يعني
عمليا بان المفاوضات قد وصلت الى طريق
مسدود اذا كان الرئيس الفلسطيني لا يعني
هذا الكلام هل تعتقد بان الرئيس الفلسطيني
اخطا بتقديم هذا المثال حتى يوصل فكره ما
لم نفهم
نحن لا المثال واضح علينا فقط ان ان نقراه
جيدا انا من بلد ما معين من 48 لا استطيع
الاقامه في هذا البلد نتيجه شيء ما معين
هو نتيجه اقامه دوله اسرائيل التي
يتحمل المجتمع الدولي ايض هو لم يقل لا
استطيع هو قال في كلمته ليس من حقي وهناك
فرق كبير بين استطيع وليس من حقي
ليس نعم ليس من حقي الحق هنا من الذي
سلبه
اسرائيل كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل حق العوده
غير قابل لا للتصرف فهو حق شخصي حق قانوني
حق تاريخي ف ولا يمكن لاحد ان
يسقطه ما بعرف انا اليوم اتابع الاخبار
واستغرب حقيقه كم هي القراء قراات خاطئه
لما تم الاستماع اليه ولكن هل القراءات
الخاطئه ايضا حتى اخطا فيها مستشار الرئيس
نمر حماد من خلال مقاله وهو مسجل بصوره
والصوت وهنا اتوجه بسؤال لسيد فايز رشيد
هل تعتقد بان الرئيس الفلسطيني سيحصل على
شيء ما من خلال ما
قاله لا اعتقد انه سيحصل على اي شيء مطلقا
سوى المزيد من الويلات والكوارث التي
جلبها والتي سيجلب لنا على صعيد الساحه
الفلسطينيه وعلى صعيد الامه العربيه لانه
ثبت بالمطلق ان نهج المفاوضات لا يمكن ان
يؤدي بالحقوق الفلسطينيه الى ان تكون
تجسيدا على ارض الواقع هذه المساله
اولا المساله ثانيا انه لا دوله على حدود
عام 67 وفق الرؤيه الاسرائيليه لا سياده
لهذه الدوله القدس عاصمه موحده وابديه الى
اسرائيل
ويعني لا انسحاب لا انسحاب الى كامل حدود
ال 67 وتواجد قوات عسكريه اسرائيليه في
غور
الاردن المستوطنات ستضم الى اسرائيل الذي
بقي يا صديقي من الضفه الغربيه هو 22% من
مساحه فلسطين التاريخيه يعني باعتراف
الجميع ان هذه الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه
حتى لا يتاهل لاقامه دوله فلسطينيه عليهم
احنا يعني بنهرب احيانا من الواقع المر
الذي نعيشه باختراع باختراع ايش باختراع
مجموعه انجازات سيد س هي هذه الانجازات
تحققت
بعد فيما يتعلق بحق عوده اللاجئين هناك
قرار دولي هو القرار 104 بحق عوده
اللاجئين هناك حق دولي بحيث انه مساله
العوده هي حق فرد لكل شخص له القدره او
الحق بان يعود او لا يعود اذا ما الذي
يدفع بالرئيس الفلسطيني الى استعمال هذه
الورقه يعني كما ذكرت لك قبل قليل منظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه السلطه الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه تقر بمقررات الشرعيه الدوليه
كلها دون استثناء خاصه القرار
194 وهذا القرار ما يحول دون تنفيذ
هم
الاسرائيليون الاسرائيليون بوانيت
بفاشل المفاوضات وهم الذين حالوا دون
عمليه السلام وبالتالي فالمسؤول هي
مسؤوليه
اسرائيليه حق العوده يا حبذ لو نستطيع ان
ننفذه اليوم قبل غدا ولكن هنالك نوع من
الترابطات الكبيره بين الطرف الاخر
الاسرائيلي وهنالك ايضا الوضع الاقليمي
والوضع الدولي ا اشكرك السيد سميح شبيب
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي كنت معنا من رام
الله وكذلك اشكر من عمان الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي فايز
رشيد بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما
وراء خبر جديد الى
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اللقاء